before we begin since Gordon just came
out the day this video is live I wanted
to issue a massive spoiler warning since
this video will cover everything about
the game's story plus scoring can also
be very gory and gross at times so if
that kind of thing bothers you in any
way I would suggest you click off since
the whole game is like this
scorn is a very conflicting game for me
I've played this game three times and I
still couldn't tell you the main story
this is due to everything in this game
being either one thing or multiple
things at one time
some of the details about this world
point to there being a literal story
here but also one that is metaphorical
but there are also details that are
extremely complex and require a deeper
analysis in order to understand but
sometimes it's just exactly what it
looks like the problem here is
determining what each thing is there is
one major contributor to this problem
and that's that scorn has no cutscenes
in dialogue nothing in this game is
actually confirmed to the player other
than what we see in front of us so a lot
of the discussion surrounding the game
is going to be Theory and that's why I'm
conflicted and confused it's hard to
critique something when you don't
understand the direction it's trying to
go in I in a way thinks scorn is a bad
game I had quite a lot of fun playing
the game and trying to put my thoughts
together but I do know that not everyone
is going to feel that way so allow me to
take some time to not only explain what
I think scoring is trying to tell us but
also if it manages to succeed in doing
so it's one thing to have a story but
trying to tell that story is something
else entirely so let's get started so
before we begin some background on scorn
it has a biomechanical kind of art style
where we play as a person
that's it scorn gives us no answers to
anything thanks to there being no
cutscenes in dialogue scorn has no
cutscenes besides a very short one at
the very beginning and end this makes it
hard to understand what's going on as
characters aren't explaining anything if
a person says their name is Ian we know
their name is Ian since the game has no
dialogue it's impossible to learn
anything this way we don't know where we
are what we are who we are why there is
flesh everywhere and why certain things
want to kill us this at the start of the
game is not a bad decision if anything
it can get people to continue playing
it's the main reason I did at least but
I'd be lying if I said I was Satisfied
by the time the credits rolled this was
the first time in years I actually felt
annoyed at this because I felt like I
had just wasted the past five hours
doing nothing for example throughout the
game we could see various mechanical
machines and structures but also lots
and lots of Flesh more often than not
these things are not separate but rather
intertwined with one another this
creates multiple questions was the flesh
already here did this flesh take over
this mechanical civilization and was it
their own creation sort of like a
civilization that ran itself into
Extinction furthermore is this flesh a
good thing is it just a part of the
world or is this flesh like a virus
taking over the world none of these
questions ever get answered and I was
stunned because I felt like I had missed
something but I also just combed through
this game multiple times so I assumed it
was on the fault of the game and not me
however I will admit I tend to think
about things logically when I see
something I ask questions from a logical
perspective like just a second ago if
these creatures are hell-bent on killing
us why are they doing it is it some
animalistic impulse or is there some
higher purpose such as killing us gives
them more flesh and then grows their
species furthermore is there a hierarchy
of beings of these species and if so who
is the leader these are logical
questions but I've come to the discovery
that scorn and well I guess art in
general don't exactly accept that way of
thinking to understand scorn it requires
you to step back and not look at it from
a traditional video game story
perspective scorn does not indulge in
these storytelling methods of a long
Exposition or a straightforward and
simplistic plot scorn seems to be more
of a complex for form of interactive art
rather than a game and in many ways
that's great games that push boundaries
like this are always a treat to play
because you never know what to expect
that's a huge reason why I love the
storytelling of the souls games and
scoring is no different scorn takes a
different approach and one I haven't
seen done to this length before where I
start to disagree though is on the
decision to not actually confirm any
information but in many ways that is the
beauty of art not understanding the
motives behind the artist and the
mindset they were in at the time allows
you to look at it from a different
perspective that's why in some cases
scorn feels like you're walking through
an interactive Art Exhibit there are
different messages in each Act and each
location is far enough apart from one
another that it's almost like different
exhibits within one Museum so let's take
it step by step and start from the
beginning before we even begin we have
to talk about the title scorn on scorn's
Kickstarter page however the game was
called something different it used to be
labeled scorn part one of two Basin or
Dives in it's a German word I don't know
how to pronounce but it means being
there presence or existence firstly
don't focus on the part one of two
things the developers did a Reddit AMA
before release and confirmed that
scoring is both parts in one so this
isn't some situation where a sequel will
be released and answer our questions
secondly the word was removed but it was
put there for a reason scorn means a
feeling or belief that someone or
something is worthless or despicable if
we're to combine the two words we're led
to believe that existence itself is
worthless or despicable or the things we
do in our existence are despicable and
worthless this could be related to the
First Act of the game we start the game
with a shortcut scene of our character
who seems to have been asleep the
branches near him have formed around his
body so it seems like he's been there
for a while they awake and then walk
forward before falling into a pit but
before that happens we see a few flashes
of another place I have a theory on this
but I need to come back to it later when
it's relevant the very beginning of the
game gets us used to some of scorn's
mechanics like many games do but we also
get a chance to look at some of the art
of scorn a lot of scorn's early levels
are very mechanical and because there is
no dialogue the sounds of the world are
more pronounced as a result just the
creaking of the machines is satisfying
to listen to
foreign
the objective of each Act is pretty much
how do we leave the current area this
means we'll have to search the various
rooms for pieces to our complex puzzle
the door stopping us from leaving has
two levers meaning we need someone or
something to pull together a lever to do
this puzzle we need to complete another
smaller puzzle that when finished drops
this sack that contains something inside
of it you either take it to the scooper
kill it then use the arm it leaves
behind to pull the lever or use the Buzz
saw which frees it allowing it to live
and help you leave this decision
ultimately changes nothing but it is a
nice way to spice up the puzzle since
there are multiple options although I
don't think there are any other puzzles
with multiple options I think this is
the only one relating this back to the
original arguments I think a lot of this
level is portraying this feeling of
worthlessness and not just in regards to
this character but also our character or
even their species all around the map
you'll find these rail cars that are
surrounded by dead bodies these row cars
also have these attachments to them
similar to the attachments seen in the
earlier puzzle meaning these rail cars
transport things and these children
inside the pods the question though is
what does this all mean I feel like it's
showing us the worthlessness of life
there are possibly hundreds if not
thousands of bodies in this room both
adult and child and they're just laying
here all over the place the buzzsaw and
the scooper also have smaller corpses
near them which would mean that some of
the procedures failed this worthlessness
could be shown in a child be rescued we
never see them again and we just leave
them here it's highly likely that
they'll be stuck there forever so we
just birthed this child just to use them
then toss them away once we no longer
needed them a lot of this game's art and
even its themes could be attributed back
to H.R gigger in this fashion you'll
recognize him as the creator of the
xenomorph from the Alien series but one
of his other pieces is called birth
machine this shows a gun being loaded
with bullets but the bullets are little
men some say that it's a message about
overpopulation and the dangers of too
many people on earth some have said it's
about the trauma of birth or even the
fact that being born is made from
violence as the gun symbolizes danger
and the men symbolize birth there's even
another art piece of his called Atomic
children which is likely about the
effects nuclear war could have in the
Next Generation it's possible that
scoring is trying to convey this but in
a different way showing that human life
in existence is a violent process many
people see reproduction as a happy and
passionate thing but some like H.R Giger
saw it differently a cold harsh method
of survival that's why the facehuggers
from Alien Attack their victims in such
a way it would force itself onto the
victim and wrap its arms around the
victim's face while shoved its tube tail
down its throat it's a violent and
assaultive process and H.R Giger used
this in his art as a way to convey the
idea of reproduction being not as
pleasant as many believe it to be scorn
seems to be implying the same thing
since all these failed births are just
left here on the ground like it's normal
human life seems to be worthless within
scorn bodies are piled up everywhere and
shipped away via rail card to another
location which is where we travel next
upon entering the next area we see even
more bodies and a Dumping Ground right
at the foot of this large device the
device in front of us looks like a heart
it's the thing that keeps the facility
moving around here and the heart is
powered by Blood but not our blood as
it's likely the blood of these people
there also seems to be a conveyor belt
that takes them inside the heart and
pushes them to other places connected to
the heart this area also has various
wires and lines connected throughout the
facility signifying the veins within our
body further confirming its likeness to
a heart there's also these machines that
are seen spraying these containers if we
keep the blood analogy going these could
be seen as the white blood cells with
the containers being the red blood cells
but this room is a perfect example of
what I hate the most about theories that
statement to you probably sounded like
the most outlandish thing I've said so
far in this video and I think so too
this is what I meant about taking things
at face value sometimes there isn't a
deeper meaning to things maybe these
robots are just cleaners and they're
just making sure the tanks still work
I've essentially been trying to find
meaning in things that may not have any
the same way a Critic might say oh the
use of purple in this painting is used
to symbolize the artist's morality when
in actuality they just use purple
because it looked cool usually
outlandish theories like this could be
disproven immediately but since we don't
even have a base of knowledge
established about scorn everything I say
could be considered outlandish it's
intentional but it's frustrating because
so many things in this game make sense
but then I read back what I wrote and
thought that's the dumbest thing I've
ever said this room is also where I came
to that idea regarding the multiple art
exhibits because I still cannot
determine how this room connects to the
rest of the game it just feels so
different from everything so far and
will continue to be as we progress
further in the context of the rest of
the game I have no clue how these
connect at all but when separated from
the rest of the world it starts to make
a bit more sense this process of
rounding up dead bodies and then taking
them by the cartilage to a Dumping
Ground which is next to a heart could
symbolize how violence and death are how
we continue to thrive in our world there
was a quote that I remember seeing a few
years ago that said something along the
lines of as long as there are two people
on Earth one will always try to find a
way to backstab the other I can't recall
who wrote that or where I saw it but I
think this Rings true in scorn we are
the only being in the world of scorn
that we know of until we save this child
and then proceed to backstab them either
by killing them or forcing them to let
us through while they stay here and
suffer there is no option to take them
with you or save them that's it you just
backstab someone you met two seconds ago
after exploring the second room we can
come across their first weapon it's
nothing much just a melee weapon of
sorts and it's pretty weak but we can
still use it on some puzzles this will
allow us to complete the puzzle in this
room and witnessed the tower we were
just plugging with something explode
after this our character will wake up in
some pod before ripping themselves out
of it this is very clearly a birth
there's an umbilical cord in everything
scorn has a strange relationship with
birth and all that this entails we saw
the children from the last room being
birthed in some way our character was
just reborn in a sense and we'll even
see this more as we continue scoring
seems to view birth as a negative thing
that being born is a Despicable act I
think lots of this game's imagery points
to this idea that the world is cold dark
depressing and full of uncertainty and
fear this Barren Wasteland we arrive at
might be continuing to push this idea as
well everyone around us has died some
have made it a few miles some only a few
feet it's symbolizing this struggle to
survive where people die every day and
violence comes as fast as the bullets
can travel this place is also where the
fleshy parts of the world start to
become very apparent my thinking is that
the symbiotic relationship between flesh
and mechanics is a dystopian one a
biomechanical is the proper term for
this and it's usually used when there's
a more balanced relationship between the
flesh in Tech the Machinery of scorn
flows together with the bloody visceral
nature of the Flesh in a weird symbiotic
way with that description there could be
hundreds of ways you could interpret
this it could show that Humanity needs
Machinery in order to live and prosper
and that this dependency will lead to
our downfall or it could be a more
positive thing that the fact that we can
use Machinery in technology shows that
we are advancing as a species I'll leave
this up to you as this idea of Flesh and
Tech interacting we'll be seen quite a
bit as we continue once we make it out
of the large Wasteland we come back to
the room where we were just in and it
looks very similar to the one in the
intro it's my theory that our character
in the intro started in the barren
Wasteland fell down the pit then woke up
at the start of the game this part of
the introduction seems to be our
character at this moment when the tower
exploded now how they managed to get
from there to the wall well like many
things in this game I'm not sure but I
do have an idea humor me for a moment
what if we aren't playing as the
original character after we are born
again we start with nothing we had that
weapon originally but now we lost it we
only get it back once we meet this
creature this thing attaches itself to
us and then latches on to us for the
remainder of the game this creature has
the same weapon attached to it quite odd
how this thing happens to have the same
exact weapon we just lost furthermore
it's even more confusing when you
consider that this is the only creature
like this in the game scorn will force
us to engage with a few different types
of enemies throughout its run time but
this is the only one of its kind meaning
this has a reason for being here I'm
going to jump ahead and talk about part
of the ending so spoiler warning but
this will be very important as we
continue to progress in the game this
creature will continue to latch onto us
and almost absorb us it will absorb so
much of us that the tree branches at
Sprouts forces us to keep the weapon we
have equipped we also can't use our
other hand and have to stab it in order
to get the tree branches to stop growing
temporarily we eventually find a way to
remove it which requires us to use this
claw machine to peel it off for us we
discover though that this thing has a
face a human face and one that looks
eerily similar to the person in the
intro we can also see that its face or
what we thought was its face is really
just a brain split in half almost like
this thing used to be human but was
transformed into this thing this all
leads me to believe that our original
character is the creature in front of us
on the main menu we also see the device
we got earlier a device our new
character does not have yet so character
a starts in the baron Wasteland falls
into the facility wakes up then carries
on until this Tower explodes killing
them then somehow it manages to form
into this creature and while this is
happening our second character comes
alive and is born this creature as I
said ends up staying with us for the
rest of the game it's a sort of weird
message about how the things that help
us often kill us and vice versa the
brain is a great example it's a very
powerful organ arguably the most
powerful organ in the body it's a
glorious part of our body that also
allows us to function but that function
may not be ideal with the brain comes
mental illness things like Alzheimer's
and Dementia occur in the brain the
thing that allows us to live this
creature is able to help us but is also
killing us it digs its hands into our
stomach and every so often will try to
kill us but it's also more than willing
to hold our equipment which expands our
inventory some of these items even allow
us to heal ourselves so it wants to
devour us but it's also willing to help
us from time to time getting back on
track from a story perspective most of
this area isn't too important as it's
just the same place as last time just
the floor above it but what is
interesting though is the very end of
this level when we finish the puzzle
these bulbous pods lower and one of them
opens to reveal a person inside we could
only open this one but each one has a
person in it just like the earlier
discussion I have an idea about what
this could mean but we'll have to hold
off on this for now but as for the being
in front of us it seems like a premature
birth in a roundabout way it probably
needed to stay in there longer and
wasn't scheduled to come out just yet
after leaving this area we end up right
back at the beginning of the game we can
see though that things have changed a
bit as there's more flesh in the area
than there was before and some of the
structures are withering away in a sense
there was a lot of this in the Wasteland
level where anything that was in flesh
was dissolving for a lack of a better
word and just kind of flying off into
the wind this is what leads me to
believe that the fleshy parts of the
world aren't actually a part of the
normal ecosystem or at least weren't
desirable because it seems to be taking
over the land the problem though is that
we never find out why or how this flesh
even got here it just appeared one day
we do end up seeing more of this flesh
as we continue and it's starting to grow
in number fast it's also here where we
get introduced to the combat of the game
it wasn't the greatest and some of the
enemies felt odd to fight as they always
seemed to hit me no matter the distance
but the combat isn't really the main
part of the game as that's reserved for
the story so as an additional mechanic
that adds more tension to the game and
also functions as a way to provide more
stimulus to the player I think it serves
its purpose well similar to the previous
area not much seems to be very
significant in terms of themes or
overall lore it just seems to be a room
with a large elevator but this does work
in collaboration with the next level as
it's here where the flesh has reached
its apex you receive an achievement when
you step into this area and its
description reads the lowest most point
this along with the giant thing in the
center leads me to believe that this is
the source of the flash taking over the
world nothing around the area though
seems to explain how this thing was
created or what purpose it serves it's
also very passive as to actually
complete this level's puzzle we need to
open up these walkways which are located
inside of it despite this act clearly
hurting this be being it doesn't attempt
to use its hands to hit us or even
summon enemies to fight us it just
stares and doesn't break eye contact
until we leave this is one of two things
I genuinely don't understand about this
game I mean if we're being honest this
whole video is just one massive Theory
but at least for everything else in the
game so far I could have provided an
explanation or an idea as to what's
going on but with this one it's
different I genuinely have no idea what
to say and that's one of my major gripes
with this game the whole point of
scoring was to have no explanation so
that we come up with our own theories
but where do we even start with this
there is pretty much nothing to go off
of all we can say is that maybe it's the
source of the Flesh and Scorn but that's
it and I feel like for something as
important as this that small sentence is
just not satisfying maybe we just have
to take it at face value and it really
is just the thing that exists in this
world and nothing more but once again
that just doesn't sit right with me at
the very least the beauty of scoring
comes out in full effect throughout this
level everything in the game has been
gorgeous in its own grotesque way but
seeing the massive chunks of flesh and
blood everywhere in this level
particularly was a sight to behold to
complete the puzzle we must solve this
maze in front of us which activates the
platform we're standing on and takes us
all the way back up to the top where the
baron Wasteland was and while we don't
actually see it for ourselves
considering the fact that this platform
was inside the creature from earlier we
likely killed it the moment we ascended
this is also the last time we see any
more of those flesh monsters so it's
almost like it's telling us that we've
defeated the evil that has infested this
land this next area is also traveled to
by train or I guess what constitutes as
a train in scoring but this area we step
foot in has no flesh it's completely
gone and I think this is due to how far
away this is from everything else
throughout my play time I couldn't help
but think that this game takes place in
a post-apocalypse and this area really
cemented that feeling for me it seems
like a place of high royalty where
people would try to flee in order to
outrun the Infectious flesh When we
arrive we see these odd statues with
people stuck to them while their brains
are connected to this hive mind of brain
matter these are possibly the higher ups
in their species like the king in his
court if you will this is also further
solidified by the images in the back
which show the brain brain basically
telling us that this is the central
nervous system of their land it's
possible that this group of people shot
off access to their facility in order to
stop the flesh from spreading because
the corpses we do see here are only the
people on the statues there are no
random dead bodies anywhere so it seems
like no one else made it to this
building this brain matter seems to act
as a sort of collective Consciousness in
which these individuals live on as a
group in a sense now a collective
Consciousness to my knowledge is more of
a mental thing like a herd mentality but
in scorn's case it seems to be more
physical as their brains are literally
extracted and taken out so that they can
be attached to the ever-growing hive
mind this place also has tons of sexual
imagery there are multiple depictions of
a man and a woman embracing one another
and are shown in positions that people
would use for intercourse there are also
lots of statues of what seem to be
pregnant women carrying children this is
quite Odd as a lot of the games so far
has shown birth as a negative thing but
this place seems to showcase the
opposite it's possible though that this
negativity was a result of this place a
place that was so obsessed with birth
that it caused overpopulation and so
Much Death that people are being carted
off in rail cars in order to get rid of
the massive spike in deaths it's sort of
like seeing a rich white picket fence
neighborhood full of happy healthy
families but right outside their gated
community is a town of homelessness and
poverty as long as you're within the
walls everything seems fine to leave
this room we have to insert blood into
these bodies that blood though won't
exactly come from a traditional Source
in this room is where we will find a
baby in some small device with a similar
color to those points from earlier which
leads me to believe that this is some
sort of reproduction for these people
these beings from earlier also have red
stomachs as well so it's possible that
this is someone in the pregnancy stage
to which they remove the device and
place it near these bulbous plants to
progress in this area we need to plant
these children in these machines the
real objective is to kill the kids and
place them in these tubes which crush
them allowing us to get their blood
which we need to proceed but the second
and third kids fight back I can only
imagine the amount of ties to abortion
this could have but it could also be the
continued idea that life is just created
to be used as we're only using these
kids to get blood in order to progress
but that device that they're in is what
interests me more it's the same color as
the being stomachs from earlier and the
plans from the previous act from a
logical perspective it could just be the
reproduction cycle for these beings but
it could also be a metaphor for how the
current kids of the world are the Next
Generation and at some point we'll be at
the helm controlling our world like this
child who controls this machine it could
also be how the acts of the parent also
translate over to them this kid probably
saw his friend get shot and killed so he
figured that he needed to fight back or
the same be done to him it's the same
way the being in the First Act was
willing to help us after We rescued him
we did an act of kindness and now he's
doing one for us but just like before
we're using these people for our own
gain and then tossing them aside when we
don't need them anymore given the
context of this facility it's also
possible that they were experimenting
with childbirth by using fake mothers
such as these in order to house the kids
plus these machines that extract the
blood fit these kids perfectly so it
seems like all this was intentional in
the room with the kids is a lot of Limbs
and I believe that these were also used
to make the machines as they have
mechanical Parts connecting their limbs
together so it seems to be an
amalgamation of different people's
bodies the question though is what is
the blood used for well it seems like it
was made for these two beings in front
of us each one of these sort of Comes
Alive once the blood is given to them
and maybe this was the final end goal
for this group of people to have two
beings carry on and fulfill whatever
they needed them to fulfill it could
even symbolize rebirth in a sense as the
first thing that came to mind when I saw
these two people were Adam and Eve the
religious Vibes kept going as to get
past the final gate we need to use our
Collective Consciousness to control each
being and use one of them to carry us up
these steps this could be a metaphor for
religion and walking up the steps past
the Pearly Gates or it just could be
literal and we're just trying to get out
of this hellscape and this is the only
way out whatever it is it didn't matter
as the creature comes back and kills our
protagonist it wraps its body around
them and transforms them into this
thing I don't even know where to begin
not in the sense that there's so much
information to unpack but in the fact
that there's not enough what do I even
say I'm just speechless I literally
don't know what to talk about I could
make an argument that this whole area is
symbolic of religion from the fact that
our character looks like he's being
crucified and then is taken from the
metaphorical cross and carried by our
new character like the pieta sculpture
made by Michelangelo and is then taken
to the Gates of Heaven before being
stopped by some outside force that could
just represent sin but I feel like I'm
just grasping at straws to make myself
feel better that's why I got so
frustrated with this game at certain
points I felt like I made so much ground
in all these discoveries like the
creatures and levels and yet I have
nothing to show for it and honestly
maybe that's the point a lot of people
Inspire the director's vision for this
game one of whom was philosopher Albert
Camus who believed that life had no
meaning that nothing exists that ever
could be a source of meaning and hence
that there is something deeply absurd
about the human Quest To Find meaning
maybe that's the point maybe scorn
wasn't meant to have meaning maybe this
is all just a pointless quest of Find
meaning in something that never had
meaning to begin with but like
everything in this video I'm not sure I
lost sleep over this game trying to
figure out what I was missing and where
I went wrong and maybe that's the point
to suffer endlessly without resolution I
don't know but that's why I made this
video scorn is a very interesting game
and despite some of the shade I've
thrown at it I did enjoy my time with it
it's an uncompromising piece of art that
is so unique you'll likely never find a
game like this again it's a truly
Unforgettable experience that I do
recommend and I wanted to make this
video to not only tell you about scoring
and be able to put all my thoughts into
words that I can feel at peace with them
for once but also to allow you to do the
same tell me what you thought about
scorn tell me about the time you had
playing this game all the theories you
came up with and all the struggles you
had to endure and maybe
just maybe
we can figure this out together
thank you all for watching today and I
hope you enjoyed it's a bit of a short
one but scoring was a short game and
there wasn't a whole lot of in-depth
stuff to talk about given what I just
said throughout this whole video scorn
is a strange one but it's hard to deny
how unique it is I've got another video
coming really soon on the Dead Space
Trilogy so look out for that it should
be out within a week or two so stick
around if that sounds interesting
regardless like the video if you enjoy
and subscribe if you're new thank you to
my returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye